You reminded me.
Well,
no,
it's not even Trump.
It's like he,
like Kim Kardashian goes to,
you know,
get Alice Marie Johnson,
like she's been fighting for this for years.
She put all of her money into a legal team to do this.
Like,
and that's not the only case she's been working on like actually trying to help
these people get clemency.
And she takes a picture and he's like,
he says something just very Ben Shapiro.
He was like,
we should not be worshiping slot buck metal.
He's worshiping us.
We're taking a meeting with communities,
not worshiping a celebrity.
These are,
that's a little extreme of an analysis for a meeting.
And the picture is taken.
Like,
you know,
I visited the present,
there's a full time photographer and every person that meets to the president,
you've got a picture in the Oval Office.
It's like a part of the system.
Um,
and yeah,
so I was just like,
dude,
shut up.
Like,
you know,
like I didn't say shut up.
I said like essentially got a good point.
In a way.
We really shouldn't be worshiping celebrity for the sake of celebrity.
And especially reality show celebrity and it doesn't mean that she couldn't have
a very valid point about prison reform.
That's what I'm saying.
She wasn't like he,
I think he said something like we shouldn't allow celebrities to shape policy.
She wouldn't go there shape policy.
She literally had a case as she's been trying to get pardoned.
The only person that can do that happens to be President Donald Trump.
It's actually,
you know,
what she's trying to do is actually very honorable.
That's what I said.
I said,
listen.
Yeah,
she,
and she's been working on it for you.
Like she's actually into this now.
Like she's into this like prison reform and I'm passionate about it.
Like I grew up seeing my uncle's in prison.
So like for me,
the only time that I like snapped back at anyone is if it's something that I
care about.
Obviously.
Like I really am passionate about black America.
I'm really passionate about the changes that can happen for black America and
prison reform or something I'm really passionate about.
So I've been observing like how hard Jared Kushner's and working on this,
how hard Ivanka has been working on this and have really understood what they're
trying to do.
Like you know,
I went to the prison reform summit,
a cup like you know,
a month ago and and Kim in this,
she doesn't even like agree with Trump and a lot of stuff.
She's thrown some shade at him.
But this is something that's awesome.
Ray Johnson case she was doing before Trump got into office.
Yes.
I love about the picture of her and him.
What she's like where the fuck over here?
Yeah,
I was taking a picture with Donald.
I'd be hugging.
Yeah.
But she,
she cares about just the case.
But look how far away she is from him.
I will say,
I will say it is awkward though because his desk is a lot lower than you than
you realize you have to like stand up straight like she's standing or like Ben,
like I bent when I was in there,
which is also kind of weird too.
So it's like you see people who either like this or they're like this and
there's no in between.
We could do like 1950s moviestar picture like this.
Yeah,
exactly.
I should.
That's what I should've done.
But yeah,
she's closer than I thought she was.
I felt like maybe I put it in my own head,
which actually a pretty God damn good right there.
She's gorgeous,
but it doesn't look anything like she used to look,
but whoever did that,
nobody does nowadays to surgeon.
You did some fun,
awesome work.
She's plump.
It looks good.
I guess the question is the kind of celebrity do a good act,
you know and sure,
of course the answer is yes.
I mean that's,
that's what Chelsea handler's trying to do.
I mean that's like she's donated,
but she really is.
She donated $1 million to a Puerto Rico.
Oh yeah.
That's good.
That should be celebrated.
That's what she's trying to do with all of her money now.
She doesn't even give a fuck about like,
which is show business anymore.
All of that stuff.
Like when they do stuff like that,
it's great and it's honorable,
but like the stuff that I hate that celebrities do and what,
which I differentiate from,
and I guess this confuses people is when they just give their opinion like we,
you know,
at like at the Emmy's and they're onstage just like teaching all of us about how
wrong our opinions are.
It's like I don't need the celebrity grand standing.
Like you know,
if there's an issue you care about other than the fact that people disagree with
you,
then sure do that.
If you care about like Ashton Kutcher going after sex trafficking,
celebrate that.
That's cool.
Like Kim Kardashian going over after a crime justice reform.
Celebrate that.
That's cool.
But when you get these celebrities that just get up there and try to deliver a
teenager,
it's like shut up.
Literally nobody cares what you think.
Like this.
Whoa.
They care enough to,
that person's got that platform and they feel like this is their opportunity to
say something significant and like also like thanking God or for sure a hundred
percent virtue signaling,
letting everybody know how moral and ethical they are,
even if they are,
I mean,
this is,
it's just those fucking award shows or weirdest shit.